Margot Robbie certainly didn't suffer
the agony of defeat to pull off this
shot but how did it come together in the
first place movie trickery is afoot are
you wondering exactly how Margot Robbie
pulled off that shot in the Barbie
trailer where she steps out of her heel
onto a perfectly arched foot apparently
a lot of people were so Robbie ended up
having to address the whole shebang
while promoting her upcoming film how
many takes was it was the shot created
using movie Magic did Robbie actually do
it not that many no and yes as Robbie
revealed in a behind the scenes
interview with Fandango it was all
probably about
eight takes wasn't that many
um they on my feet I walked up we had
little sticky bits on the floor for the
like double-sided tape for the shoes so
they wouldn't
come off so that I could get my feet out
of them and I was holding onto like a
bar but that's it I wasn't like a
harness or anything like that I just
like walked up kind of held onto the bar
above camera asked if she was a dancer
based on her high arch Robbie said I did
ballet when I was a kid but still her
point was that she wanted to do the shot
herself I always try and do my own
inserts like I don't like when I watch a
movie and I know it's not my hands I
hate that swim I always say the direct
away please let me do all my own things
I don't I don't like knowing that I
didn't do it if you're anyone who ever
played with Barbies as a kid you know
exactly why this shot was so vital to
the trailer and the overall film those
who have played with a Barbie know that
her plastic foot is always perfectly
arched ready to slip into whichever pair
of shoes you decide to choose next and
the journey Robbie's Barbie takes in the
movie is revealed through her lack of a
Sharp Arch when Barbie's foot goes flat
she shows her Barbie friends only to
receive a horrified reaction as they
realize she's less than perfect others
strange happenings are going on too her
clothes don't dress her on their own
anymore she can't float off her roof
without falling and injuring herself and
she can't stop thinking about dying
perplexed Barbie visits weird Barbie a
Barbie erratically styled by her owners
and played by Kate McKinnon who presents
a shoe-related conundrum you have to go
to the real world you might look at
Margot Robbie and think yeah that's what
Barbie looks like and you probably
wouldn't be alone in a Time feature
about the film Mattel Executives
basically stopped short of saying
exactly that Robbie for her part was
smart enough to know that this movie
needs to be more than a close look at
how Barbie is blonde and beautiful and
along with writer director Greta Gerwig
she made sure that the film features a
diverse array of actors playing Barbies
Robbie told the magazine if Mattel
hadn't made that change to have a
multiplicity of Barbies I don't think I
would have wanted to attempt to make a
Barbie film I don't think you should say
this is the one version of what Barbie
is and that's what women should aspire
to be and look like and act like
insecure star and Creator Issa Ray who
plays President Barbie in the film
clearly agrees in the same feature she
said my worry was that it was going to
feel too white feministy but I think
that it's self-aware Barbie land is
perfect right it represents Perfection
so if Perfection is just a bunch of
white Barbies I don't know that anybody
can get on board with that not only did
Robbie and Gerwig craft an inclusive and
diverse world full of Barbies all
crushing it in their own right but by
their own account they worked together
to create a fun subversive and clever
film even though it's centered around a
toy and overseen by a toy company they
still ran into some problems when it
came to the Mattel overlords though
according to the time article Robbie and
Gerwig had to perform one scene live for
president and CEO of Mattel Richard
Dixon who objected to well whatever
happens in it because we still don't
know performing it in person worked
though and he agreed to keep the scene
Robbie clarified when you look on the
page the Nuance isn't there the delivery
isn't there ultimately it's about being
in on the joke and apparently that's a
concept Robbie had to explain to
Mattel's CEO ya known cries in that very
first meeting we impressed upon you
known that we are going to honor the
legacy of your brand but if we don't
acknowledge certain things if we don't
say it someone else is going to say it
so you might as well be a part of that
conversation Robbie definitely took
charge of the Barbie movie and as a
result it looks amazing including that
iconic foot shot performed by the Oscar
nominee herself Barbie hit theaters on
July 21 2023
foreign